[Music]
we're racing toward the extinction of
our species
we not only lack dominion over nature
[Music]
we're subordinate to it
guys the movie was amazing oh
my gosh i loved it that much you're warm
i'm actually warm it was like all the
virtual running that i did in this game
yes we're kidding you've seen the movie
i have not seen the movie so tell me how
epic it is
epic is the word
yeah and it's i mean this is the sixth
jurassic park movie and it's the first
where all of us are in it together and
so if that's not epic like
what is a scale of one to 100
epicness oh it's it's in the high
hundreds
it's it's a triple digits
on only just one just to 100 yeah 160.
it is it's the scope is unlike anything
you've ever seen in one of these films i
mean you'll see
as the rest of the world is seeing at
the same time uh
and you know god willing in theaters uh
it's it's it's massive and you've got
jeff goldblum and sam neil and laura
dern all back you've got a bunch of
amazing new characters you've got uh
claire and owen and dinosaurs you've
never seen before and truly colin has
done just a masterful job it does truly
feel like this franchise has been not
just 65 million years in the making but
65 million and 30 years
in the making okay we're done that was
it that was great yeah
that was perfect
but honestly for all of you to have that
legacy cast on set can you talk about
the first day i'm assuming there was a
moment where you were all together on
set don't want spoilers but what was
that moment like
all right so my first day on set was
with um sam and laura
and heard of them
and i just remember being on this
helicopter
and looking at them and sam's wearing
his iconic hat and laura's there and i'm
just like what am i
doing here like this is so it was so
nerve-wracking but they were so
wonderfully open and like just generous
it was exciting you started working with
them early first yeah yeah by the time i
was working with them i'd already lived
with them for three months so
i could tell because you went to a hotel
together we were all at the hotel
together so by that point you know it's
it's like it's working with your friends
okay so i need to know what happened at
the hotel did you guys get up to
shenanigans was it we i mean we did
every it was we lived at the hotel we
made meals together
great meals great meals incredible
her husband alana miller was there and
he was the most amazing host and kind of
captain of the entire we were we were
both ras and it showed you guys
you were those
assistants
you know the truth is is that a lot of
us had
our families with us and so there were a
lot of young kids around so the
shenanigans were
were
very innocent and fun and
like
family-like you know familial we we all
like to wanda said we were all eating
together we were all hanging out
together you would play frisbee on the
weekends you know it's it was something
that was really
special and we treasure and there wasn't
drama which was incredible you know yeah
yeah we decided everything surrounding
was dramatic enough so we were good yeah
well i like how everyone was growing
my frisbee time because i you know it's
directing a movie of this size is a
challenge and there was just this one
hour every sunday everyone knew from one
to two colin gets to play frisbee yeah
that's the only time that he gets that's
that's what i would do
the most epic movie of all time
i want to ask you i know that you shared
a photo with steven spielberg
with the legacy cast on set he got
emotional
you watched jurassic park you snuck out
of your house as a 13 year old watched a
midnight showing
this must be such you've dreamt about
this and you've said that making a movie
you make the movie you want to see as a
kid so how did you go about doing that
and you think you accomplished it
well in a lot of ways this was the movie
that i've been trying to earn
for you know eight years we made these
two other movies to build up
uh just to the the possibility for this
movie to exist and the fact that we got
to to have characters that you now know
and care about uh in in bryce and chris
new characters that you're just meeting
and then uh these icons that are that we
have to stand alongside that i have to
speak to with both tremendous respect
and yet also we are working we're making
a movie so i have to find this balance
in between it uh i think all of us had
similar a similar set of feelings where
there were times when i would walk into
this group and just look around it's
like icon icon i cannot get me
i and yet at a certain point you just
have to you know focus up and and try to
make something extremely entertaining i
remember the first jurassic park there's
the banner that falls over the t-rex
that says dinosaurs rule the earth is
this the full circle now moment from
that where dinosaurs it's now flipped in
a sense do you feel that that's sort of
the vibe and the tone of this film yeah
well that shot uh posed a question to me
that i think that we followed through
that if
if this technology created a scenario
where we had to share the earth with
dinosaurs
is it possible that we could go extinct
and they would get to uh have the earth
back uh and there was something uh
really just holistic and and huge in
that idea that we if we don't you know
if we don't take care of the planet
we're on maybe our time's up now and and
they get it back i have my theories
about how it's going to all end i i
can't wait to see it and find out if i'm
right or not
the two of you i asked the legacy cast
this already their favorite moments of
each other when they watch back the
films i want to know each of your
favorite moments of each other from the
previous films or including this film if
you can tell us something without
spoilers i love chris on a motorcycle
i love chris on a motorcycle too and i
haven't even seen the film yet but from
the trailer surrounded by raptors
not in real life though do not ride
motorcycles in real life just don't
but in a movie
it's great
yeah that's a good moment i gotta say
watching the evolution of of claire that
uh character that bryce plays so
beautifully it's really an amazing arc
from
first movie second movie the third movie
and to see now in this third movie
some straight up action hero yes
badassness coming from you as you're
like running across rooftops and malta
jumping from roof to roof you know
using like uh
using a taser to blast somebody and like
out running dinosaurs it's it's
claire's come a long way and can you
speak to that a little bit because this
film is obviously this is a very
different film in the sense that we're
finally out of the jungle do you feel
like this is like the james bond of
jurassic like it almost feels like that
worldwide did it feel very different for
you as actors this time around yeah of
course i mean what what feels more
different than anything is is that we're
really off the island like really really
off the island and whereas in in
previous jurassic films it's so you know
the island is so central to the
narrative
and in fallen kingdom
he blew up the island this guy here and
so
and so now
now you know dinosaurs are everywhere
and
you get to see some really kind of
extraordinary arresting visuals that
you've never seen before dinosaurs in
snow you know like there is that whole
sequence in malta like it's it's really
really really thrilling to imagine you
know what if dinosaurs were absolutely
everywhere around the entire planet and
it truly is epic in scope not just from
the locations that we shot and they shot
all around i mean
how many continents four different
continents or something like that and so
it does have that feeling that you would
get from a bond movie or something it's
it's truly global and the set pieces
that were built each and every day
uh we'd you know we'd spend maybe
anywhere from two days to maybe a week
or more on some of these sets and the
sets themselves it was like you were
inside of a theme park that truly as as
you know john hammond said
we spared no expense this is a big
big
expensive movie
and uh you you can feel it when you see
every frame of the i just when i saw the
film i looked over the guy the guy next
to me i was like
are you are you kidding me
are you
freaking kidding me
every
every new set you're just like what in
the actual [ __ ] like this
he did it yes
sorry
it just feels it feels huge yeah and it
is it's it's it is massive yeah dewand
and mamadou new characters coming into
this what can you tell us about each of
who you play
well yeah i play this uh bison executive
ramsay cole um highly driven highly
motivated and i i was telling colin
earlier i wish i could be like him
in real life um just this hyper-focused
uh mission-oriented guy that you know
just has his eye on the ball every time
is it true that colin saw one of your
movies and approached you like did you
get a phone call going hey do you want
to be in jurassic world and what is it
like getting that phone call
kind of pretty much yeah that's so crazy
[Laughter]
no it's um it's an incredible honor um
and i i mean i at that time i had only
seen his first feature and i was like oh
i got to work with this guy and we had
such a great conversation and it was
very much um about collaboration
first and foremost which really meant a
lot to me and told me a lot about the
filmmaking process and that lived up to
its promise so yeah it was great yeah
colin kind of spoiled this actually in
the process because i know this isn't
how it's supposed to go like i know that
we had essentially what like a two week
basically my quarantine was like a
workshop we just workshopped it we were
like you know on the phone or like on
email or on zoom or whatever uh just
kind of like
refining her and
filling the backstory into the you know
into the feature and into the costume
and into the dialogue and you know it
was really this kind of indie really it
was like a very independent film
experience like people i actually don't
know what it feels like yet to work on
my first blockbuster because
all the infrastructure of everything was
just like i know my crew members names
you know what i mean like um
so yeah it was uh it's very special
super intimate um
and still surreal kayla is the best yeah
but
say a little bit about your character
what's the deal with kayla uh the deal
with kayla kayla kayla watts is former
u.s air force
uh so she has like this wonderful kind
of thread with owen in that former like
military background and when you first
meet her it's very clear she's like
absolutely fine and not only fine but
like super happy on her own so she's a
voyeur she's an adventurer she's super
scrappy you know she's like early career
harrison ford and i love her so much
did i get a hat no i got gloves oh yes
she did
[Laughter]
colin i know two of the two of the
things that make jurassic world i think
work is that you care as much about the
people and the actors because they
become national treasures as you do the
dinosaurs but i know you've been saving
up some of the dinosaurs for this
particular film how did you choose and
why did you why did you want to save
them for this film
well it probably the best part of my job
is is that i get to be in a little
sandbox and and whichever dinosaurs and
i'm playing with at the time i get to
put those in the movie and so i also
have to keep some of them in the corner
of the sandbox and make sure to to save
them and we saved for this movie some of
my favorites we saved dinosaurs with
feathers uh giganotosaurus which is the
largest land-based carnivore what's the
line again
she says it in the movie i love that her
character about a year ago
she
is the one who actually has the dinosaur
knowledge in the movie and just knows
everything about all of them and you
know it's
that part of that part is a blast
realizing them making these you know
incredible animatronics all of the
resources that we were given on this
movie to
just
make it something that felt just real
and tactile and and authentic and i'm so
proud of that part i can't speak to its
quality i have to let them do that i
just lay the film at your feet and ask
you hopefully you will enjoy it
but the craftsmanship behind it
is extraordinary i just have one last
question do you guys because every time
i see a film or think about interviewing
you guys the song is stuck in my head
constantly do you guys have the same
thing when you're on set in filming oh
all the time it's a dinosaur
if jeff goldblum is not actually singing
it at the time yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
can you do it all together to go out
sure yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
congratulations on the film thank you
thank you so much
you